wollte in ruhe auf dem balkon meinberg
money zählen und zip dazu so 1 uhr saft
mit einmal tropf tropf verbrannt 20
brutales komm rein gestürmt und werfen
mich rückt servos und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video in dem
ich ein thema ansprechen möchte dass die
welt verändern wird heute am ersten juni
2015 hat sich der orangensaft skandal
ereignet endlich hat sich ja was ist
denn der orangensaft skandal von dem es
spricht ich will es euch zeigen leute
ist das so geil oder wird sie wartet auf
facebook hat ich sterbe es ist so
fucking witzig guckt hier passt auf wir
spielen vielleicht löcher meinte
minecraft aber erstmal möchte ich euch
das hier zeigen so dafür machen wir
jetzt dem einfach im browser davor so
funktioniert es funktioniert nicht nach
sechseinhalb stunden später leute hier
ist das ding auf der facebook page von
moneyball könnte ich das nochmal
anschauen wir schauen zu sehen sondern
mal gemeinsam an
es ist einfach genial im ritz carlton
dazu muss man sagen dass witz gehalten
ist ein sehr sehr gutes und relativ
teures berliner hotel und der boj war da
und hat voll gemacht
was man vorne vollbild geht nicht auf
weil wir sie nie im ritz carlton und
dürfen nicht einchecken weil orangensaft
verschüttet wurde
frage mich was für saft einfach
organisatoren hab einfach angst
ich frage mich was für saft wird einfach
einfach würde sie bitten jetzt leben was
fragen sie mich nicht an
das ist nämlich homo er ist so krass so
fertig und jetzt das beste wenn man
jetzt auf die facebook-page vom ritz
carlton geht das sind so geile
rezensionen was mich alles nicht gucken
ritz-carlton berlin
hier ist es ist es das ritz carlton
berlin
aha sehr leisten jetzt geht man hier
auch bewertungen es ist so geil so geil
ohne witz wegen autos gebrannt worden
seht ihr vater ihr seht ihr das gleiche
wie ich hier oben jetzt wegen audios
gewarnt worden
saft oder hier unter aller sau
nicht mal in ruhe o saft kann man
trinken wenn man einchecken möchte nie
wieder
sogar ein alter wollte in ruhe auf dem
balkon meinberg money zählen und zither
21 uhr saft mit einmal tropf der tropfen
vom rand rund 20 brutales kommen rein
gestürmt und werfen die frage mich was
soll das nicht was für saft einfach
orangensaft mann ist das nice eines ist
so geil da gibt es auch noch
es gibt noch andere kann man hier
irgendwie sortieren auf jeden fall die
bewertung gehen krass runter hier so
erwarte man dass der vestia dieser
artikel den wir diesen dieser milchshake
oder schreibt die ganze zeit da
irgendwie so ein käse sei es genau hier
passt mal auf das schauen wir uns doch
allen dann spielen wir hier
hallo liebes karten team wird nun
eineinhalb jahren bin ich stammgast bei
ihnen im haus mit meinem kollegen herrn
obst ab mit dem er ein stück obst so
oder kommentiert der diese andere tut
herr obst darf einchecken aber der boyle
darf sein orangensaft nicht mitnehmen
für hack zeichen hashtag einfache häuser
sagt skoda superb josef jung heißt alter
ist auf jeden fall mal an wie gesagt es
kalt in berlin und facebook von money
money boys ist so heißt es ist einfach
geil so jetzt hat früher mal kräftig
bisschen cool es gehe hier
ich habe mir gedacht komm scheiß drauf
wir hatten jetzt einfach mal drauf hier
ich halte einfach mal drauf
als würde ich einen druckverband
auflegen anlegen weil ich halt einfach
mal drauf ist so ja dann kümmert
spielleute schreibt meine kommentare
darum gehalten habt richtig hier lässt
man sagt alter zwei djs aus den erst
zwei kisten und trotzdem werde verkannt
keller verharrt
es ist nicht euer ernst als kannten
euer ernst sein kann ich nicht verstehen
wenn leute hoch bis zum zweck gemacht
ihre oma die um 11 uhr
ich habe das zeug gekettet ist so ich
bin das organ gärten meine haare sind
immer noch wie ein mofa ich habe mir
gerade eine pizza bestellt und chill
einfach heute man es ist so entspannt
mein semesters jetzt größtenteils rum
warum machte sich war für einen seite
orientieren
orientalische einrichtungen könnte man
mir kaufen von balduin und wo kommt
schon danger tv natürlich versuchen zu
legen
ich mach dich kaputt alte optimistisch
experience gerade leichtes moodle
ex-lover es geht ihr mit dem ob ein blog
ist ein blog steht ja nein nein gema weg
hier man retten aber mal der andere und
wollte mich gelten deswegen müssen wir
ein bisschen dran als wäre es nichts für
uns
als wäre es nichts kommt es auf mich so
hab ich dann wird man brot zu ihnen
zählte brot wie jemand der gerne
backwaren konsumiert er auch gegen super
das war nicht besonders krass ja wo kann
man lang gehen hier
wie wär's denn hier lang und jetzt auf
verkehr incoming gut gesungen
komm ich hole ich hole ich alter schwede
knappe sache fucking knappe sache ich
muss immer aufpassen gerade hier helm
und ok also ich weiß jetzt auch warum
meine mentale bisschen her springt
nämlich euch den abriss muss runter
gefallen was geht dir brands team oder
ist sagt er ist [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
jetzt habe ich den goldman gold apple
bietet jetzt hätte ich dich okay nur
hätte auch in gold apfel hoya den nehme
ich mit und weiter laufen bei der
laufenden bewegung bleiben
er ist glaube jetzt voll durch
gebrettert okay da kommt noch ein
anderer
so jetzt steht erstmal ab das sind die
beiden letzten gegner die höheren warte
mal bin ich im team steves verboten
runde aber nur weil ich jetzt gerade so
bisschen weiß nicht ob die sich gerade
nicht angegriffen
für mich komisch aus sie greifen ist ja
alles klar
joy nicht doch einfach mal die runde
rein
na komm meego das von nokia andere
übertreiben
was für ein ninja move holy cow gott ich
bin doch nicht bedauert nein nein nein
junge samt darauf mich drauf man aber
gut gemacht von ihm scheiße
manipulativen die version heißt aber
okay gut leute dann man kann nicht immer
alles gewinnen ich hoffe das video durch
trotzdem unterhalten schreibt einen
kommentar was ich dazu einfällt wir
sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
morgen also bis dahin haut rein macht
google und yahoo